of course there's four things that we
all need to do and it's very similar to
it's very similar to the infinite game
which is these are practices you know if
you do one of them you'll be better but
if you do all of them you're the best
but you can't do them all well all the
time you know you need to get sleep you
need to eat well you need to exercise
you need to maintain your close personal
relationships you have to do all of them
all the time how annoying right and so I
can recognize that when one or two of
those things have fallen away you know
I'm on the road a lot diet goes to pot
very quickly sometimes exercise goes
away and those things are pressed rating
I immediately feel it but for me it's
the social one that's the biggest one
and if I feel myself struggling you know
I'll call someone I'm very very close
with my sister and she and I are very
lucky to have each other you know I'll
call her and say I'm having a bad day
where I can't figure this out or I don't
know how to do this where I'm stuck I'm
struggling you know and those
relationships are so important because
sometimes we yell and scream at each
other but we don't it's not at each
other it's because we're frustrated the
other person just stays and listens you
know I was really funny I was at this I
was at this meeting once and those woman
sitting next to me who apparently was a
big tiny yoga instructor and she was on
her phone the entire time at this
meeting like under the table and it
wasn't like a grandparent was sicker in
hospital and like she needed to stay
connected or something like that you
know I could I looked over she was in
social media sure and at one point we
were talking about being present and she
perked up and said that's why I love
yoga it helps me be present she
completely missed is that we don't get
to decide when we're present you know I
like yoga helps me be present good for
you you know like other people get to
decide when you were present that's the
standard the reason we meditate you know
if any of you have ever meditated you
know you learn to sit there and clear
your mind and if you have a thought you
label a thought you put it out of your
mind to deal with later which is hard to
do but the reason a meditation practice
is important is when you're sitting in
someone's talking to you that you're not
waiting for your turn to speak that when
you have thoughts you learn to label
those thoughts and put them aside so you
can be totally present for the other
person and you are not president present
until someone else says to you thank you
for listening
I feel heard thank you for being there
for me congratulations all that hard
work has now paid off being present is
an act of service and that's what we
think we've forgotten in America today
which is all of these you know work-life
balance pursuits have become selfish
pursuits you know we have an entire
section in the book shop called
self-help we have no section in the book
shop called help others and I think this
is a problem and I blame this the 80s
and 90s ok bloomer I do I blame I blame
a lot of what happened with the baby
boomers a lot of those theories of
business and prioritizing self before
service and me before we they really
they really took off in the 80s and 90s
which were which were relative peace and
and booming economically everybody was
getting rich in the 80s in Chains and so
we did we became super selfish and I
think we're paying the price these days
because I think as a society as an
American society we've over indexed on
selfish and we need to get back to
service
[Music]